When it comes to performance
Sometimes it is not the big flagrant subjects that are causing the most problems,
They are small things that when added together create huge problems for your application.
My name is Colt McCannless,
One of the ideal examples of small things combined that lead to major problems,
Is an advantage in Java programming language known as Autoboxing automatic packaging
Note that for Java, initial styles like int, bool and float
Great for matching IEEE standards and hardware definitions.
But this also prevents them from being used
With public groups provided by the operating environment.
Instead, Java provides versions of objects from these primitive styles
Such as java.lang.Integer
Which give you the same functions as the initial correct pattern,
But can be used with public groups.
This is where the role of automatic packaging comes.
Automatic packaging at its core
Converts from initial patterns to their counterparts of objects on your behalf,
So you do not have to worry about any of those conversions in your code
Which is pretty cool overall
Take this simple loop, for example.
We can handle the Integer object easily
In the same way if it is an initial correct pattern without any additional installation.
But unfortunately, the nature is free of manual control of this function
Come with some performance penalties.
Note, for each step of the Integer object copy of the loop,
The operating environment must create a new Integer object and put an initial value in it
Before they are able to be added to the other Integer object.
This means that at any time you convert automatic packaging,
The allocation of a new object will occur with it.
Compare this with a copy using primary styles that do not require any additional allocation loads.
This is really painful to watch,
Because these organisms are larger than their primary counterparts,
Where the Integer object takes a size of 16 bytes, instead of four for the initial style
Further performance is also required to achieve the desired value
It mainly creates a double blow to memory issues and operating environment performance.
Now, you need to be aware that this problem does not simply appear
With our fabricated examples like a loop for here
Both. It appears at any time correlates a general set with an initial pattern,
It is a special problem for containers such as HashMap.
Basically any time you do by inserting, modifying, or retrieving values
With this general container, while there is a primary pattern included,
It will eventually end up with encapsulated or uncoated values
Which is the exact reason for the availability of the Android platform
Custom containers to be used in these cases instead of HashMap
The family of SparseMap containers
All designed specifically to combat the problem of automatic packaging
Which eliminates both operating environment additions and reducing their impact on memory.
Now if you are not sure where automatic encapsulation can cause trouble in your code,
Android Studio tools can help you track it
If you use the Customization Tracker tool, keep your attention anywhere
You have a set of Integer objects that all come from a single calling site.
In TraceView, watch out for an influx of calls to Integer.value
For any reason given.
Each of these reports is a clear sign of automatic packaging.
While low performance level
Is the easiest and most common fix found on it,
These small problems start with really accumulating and really cause great problems if left unchecked.
This is why you need to check out the rest of the content of Android performance patterns
To see what is also working in the shade
And, certainly, do not forget to join our community on Google+ as well
For tips and other great tips.
So keep calm, write your code, and always remember, performance is important.